So our second combined therapy, are the integrative therapies. And these are
eclectic. And by eclectic what we mean is that the therapist can use any
technique he or she feels is best for the situation. So for example, in
treating post traumatic stress disorder, sometimes we use prolonged exposure
therapy. And prolonged exposure therapy is a combination of cognitive
behavioral therapy and systematic desensitization and relaxation therapy. So
the idea here is that the person thinks about, is exposed to the trauma in
their, in their minds, they imagine it, but at the same time, they also are
relaxed and have to stay relaxed. So, if that happens, they become desensitized
to the trauma and it no longer bothers them. Now sometimes, in fact, drugs
might also be added to this combination to help treat the anxiety and help with
the relaxation.